letztendlich werden darüber die
strafverfolgungsbehörden entscheiden
denn es ist ja bereits strafanzeige
erstattet worden ich glaube durch die
deutsche polizeigewerkschaft
ich ahne wie dieses ermittlungsverfahren
ausgeht ich selber halte diesen text für
unsäglich
jetzt fehlt nur noch dass diejenigen die
diesen text für unsäglich halten in die
ecke gestellt werden sie würden jetzt
die pressefreiheit in deutschland in
gefahr bringen
wenn es ohne konsequenzen möglich wenn
nicht mehr möglich wäre gruppen in
dieser form zu beleidigen
ich habe in 68 jahren selten einen
schlimmeren text gelesen und jetzt jetzt
kommt der berühmte satz von kurt
tucholsky satire darf alles dass bayer
nur spaß es ist ja nur ein literarischer
scherz gemacht worden ist doch nicht
ernst gemeint wäre in dieser form für
polizistinnen und polizisten sozusagen
auf der müllhalde entsorgen will man
muss bei den ganzen artikel lesen
das ist ja nur der höhepunkt einer ganz
traurigen argumentation
das ist ja geradezu unmenschlich wieder
mit den beamtinnen und beamten
umgegangen wird dass das überhaupt in
der taz die halten sich ja da seit
jahrzehnten für moralisch besonders hoch
stehen veröffentlicht werden konnte das
überrascht mich schon ich weiß auch dass
es debatten gibt in der redaktion
ob man diesen text überhaupt hätte
veröffentlichen dürfen oder nicht
ich gehe mal davon aus dass das
ermittlungsverfahren im sande verläuft
aber wer diesen text für unsäglich hält
und kritisiert er bringt nicht die
meinungsfreiheit in gefahr
herr gabriel wiesen sie pro klasse so
schön stilvoll gesagt sag jetzt mal so
wie man das wort sagen würde die hat
nicht alle latten am zaun
das kann doch nicht wahr sein dass eine
chefredaktion auch so etwas durchgehen
lässt
vor allem bei aller verständnis für die
debatte um meinungsfreiheit wie ich oder
liste die das geschrieben hat wie kann
das deshalb schreiben weil sie in einem
rechtsstaat lebt davon
die zeit die sie bestimmt beschütze er
geht es offensichtlich so gut und ich
waren anders kann ich würde das jetzt
erklären wie kann man dieses lang und
die guten verhältnisse in denen wir hier
leben gibt milliarden menschen auf der
welt wie würden sich diese art
demokratischer polizei wünschen die wir
in deutschland haben
wie kann man die derartig beleidigen und
dazu fällt mir ehrlich gesagt nichts
höflich ist mir ein wenn ich wolfgang
gerne zugehört habe der das mit großem
stil bewusst sei neben verpackter seine
kritik ich wie gesagt bin ich ganz bei
trost die dame die das geschrieben hat
vielleicht habe ich ja jetzt eine
anzeige weil ich mich der hatte ich über
sie äußere aber was anderes fällt mir
das turnier ein